yeah mike pence was trump's vp
and um it was kind of interesting
because trump was like you know how
trump is and mike pence was like the
most clean cut like like conservative
like like true when you think of like a
traditional
conservative man like with one woman has
the like picture perfect family
and he had he was very religious and he
had a rule that he would not be alone
with a woman like that wasn't his wife
so if if he was with another woman he
would always have a chaperone and back
then everyone made fun of him they were
like why would you do that like you
can't be alone with a woman like making
fun of him
and it's interesting because after this
like me too culture
he was smart he was smart he must had a
really bad exp sorry he must have had a
really bad experience to do that i don't
think he i don't think he did if you
like he he doesn't really
complain about it he probably just
understands the system yeah
i think it's just in politics like
i think when you're a man and you have
power and money
there's
always crazy women that are going to try
to get it their numbers true and yeah
that's the thing like and the thing is
there's no handbook for men
to
to show them how to handle that type of
power
because you know power generally
corrupts people you know ultimate power
corrupts but
um
imagine that i don't know like you could
be a married man like i said tiger woods
[Music]
and 18 women have said yeah i had sex
with that guy
and it's like
there's nothing i said no in men's
nature and i think it's a a lot of the
thing is that men know their nature and
they know they're weakened by it and
women know men's nature and they know
they can make a man weak
and so a lot of the time
she's just her face
like they know they can make a man we
can eat whether you believe in the
religious scriptures or not you can go
back as far as them and say samson and
delilah adam and eve like a man is
always is downfall a lot of men's
downfall have always been like women do
you know what i mean
again
yeah it's always been like starting a
war
and so i think i think we're living in a
different time now where that type of
manipulation has been like enhanced
for women and they know how to use it
it's been encouraged and it's been
it's been pedestalled
it's been encouraged to manipulate men
in that way
so that we can exploit what they give to
us so financially
we want to be independent but we
acknowledge that men give us financial
um give us more equity
do you get what i mean so we're
independent but we want your money too
but even in
and then just to add to that we don't
want marriage
which gives us the bond and the entitled
not entitlement entitles women to what
men have
but we want what they have you don't
have to say that we have power
but we
but then at the same time
what is our power we don't acknowledge
that part
you don't think women want marriage
i mean i feel like women want it they
just can't get it from the guys they
want no no that's true yeah
they want they want marriage on their
terms and that's not how marriage works
oh yeah yeah i want to marry you yeah
you know like wait so you're not the
type of men that women want to marry
they want to marry those top 20 of no no
but you like now you go to socials you
see you see women proposing to men that
is just i find that so oh cringe
wait but
i'm confused first of all can i just say
something to some of the chats because i
feel like i've been attacked a little
bit which i didn't expect go ahead i
didn't expect it okay i did just
quit yeah yeah yeah
whatever type of way that they would
feel but this is me and i am getting my
help that i need so it's not it's not
like i'm coming here to just try and
make it seem like i'm a victim and
whatever it is speaking on what you're
saying about um women wanting to be
independent but wanting men's money i
can tell you for a fact i call myself
the independent parent because i am and
i don't want their mouths to say
anything about me
hang on when i say being a woman no
listen listen quickly being a woman and
being independent you are saying oh
sorry my sorry this mic is a bit a bit
true yeah but
so being a woman and being independent
being a woman and being independent you
are saying you do not you're independent
yeah but really your independence
because you need a man to support what
you're doing for you to feel empowered
no in that moment no no i'm not saying
you oh i'm just saying yeah
in general
women are claiming independence but they
want all the thrills that come with
relationships and marriage so which one
do you want because there's a level of
sacrifice and partnership that comes
with not even compromise just
partnership
partnership is being able to communicate
being able to listen being able to
commit to conflict resolution
take accountability for your part to
play in the problem
take accountability for
your position in your partnership but
wait when a woman accepts that
accountability for their part to play
they looked at oh so you did do this
yeah you did to do that
and so
then what happened no no but so what
because i feel like it makes it easier
for a woman to be blamed no no so what
you're taking accountability for your
part to play right and somebody else's
opinion on your part to play is
irrelevant your relationship is what
you're accountable for right so if you
and your partner have a discussion and
you both acknowledge your accountability
in the in the problem it can be resolved
but the problem is the problem is
everybody
is you it's me yeah excuse me
that's but that's the issue i feel like
it's we're in a situation this is what i
was saying about the recording each
other it becomes a war on well look you
did this but look you did that so what
is the benefit of both women and men
recording i told you
earlier women don't go to jail i've i've
never mendy
had a reason for a guy to record me like
i don't wait like what is women don't go
to women don't get arrested men that's
what i was just trying to say this
remember originally men all the time
every day get arrested for this
including myself you don't know how many
men are there only women being arrested
for a man recording and showing to the
police
do you know how many men are probably
sitting down in prison right now wishing
that they've recorded something that had
actually happened to them
and
um it made me wonder
specifically with the johnny heard thing
um johnny heard johnny depthing um that
had he not how many men did not have
what he had
how many men
are sitting down in prison now thinking
[ __ ] if i just recorded that [ __ ] but i
don't think because then just not
believed yeah but rape cases and all
that but him being johnny depp gave him
leverage in that situation
and it still happened to him that's the
crazy part
in that situation let's be real if
johnny depp was some black guy from
newham and he was in that situation
would he get the same reception if
johnny depp
was the average guy from down edmonton
some guy would anybody care would they
have so much spotlight on it well it
kind of says that no
right but
that's my point it's like how many how
many average dudes
have been through the same situation at
a time
yeah how many averages have been for the
same situation
and they're sitting down in prison yeah
i agree and i agree with you on that but
with the recordings or not
you know
the recordings themselves they're not
they're not the
evidence that leveraged the case in this
situation really it was the fact it was
a high profile case it generated money
again it's about generating money
for the average man he
has he's at a disadvantage at every
point
so financially he's getting rinsed
um
emotionally he's getting rinsed he can't
talk about it there's nowhere for him to
turn
um
mentally where can you turn
do you get what i mean where is johnny
depp openly
sorry something that i've learned with
just being on the podcast and watching
the videos i've watched with pearl
men's
men's brains are
just they just operate so different from
women so you're saying just because your
man is like yeah just because they're
men they understand and that's that's
how simple it is when it comes to man's
brain it's
it's
mind-blowing men is simple
yeah it's mind-blowing that it's just
like that because i'm like wait how how
what do you mean just because you're a
man how do you understand that and like
women's brains they think so much more
about menses
it's kind of like how men they like
they'll never understand how crazy we
feel like a week before a period like
three days they will never understand
just how irrational and how not like
yourself like they will never have that
feeling this is this is where the
emotion comes into it when we're talking
about like obviously like we said it's
not acceptable when we talk about like
women's emotions and their responses
sometimes we are irrational as women
simply because we have certain hormones
and doesn't make it acceptable
but it's like there have been cases
where because of that alone or simply
because a woman has recently given birth
or she was on her period or whatever it
was
unfortunately she has been excused from
certain things because she was not in
her right frame of mind when
committed you saying that are you now
saying that being on your period is some
kind of mental schizophrenia or
something because being on your period
the pain that you get on your period
to be equivalent to having a heart
attack
[Music]
i don't believe that you didn't hear
that i don't believe that
you're period now you don't like that
discussion
guys guys
there might be a study that says that
but like some studies i just i don't
believe that's a dangerous thing
i wouldn't say that for all women there
are some women who go through severe
severe
period cramps for me i don't i don't
deal with that mine aren't severe so for
me to
for as a woman be like oh so if this
woman
says that she can do this that in the
third on her period and her cramps are
astronomical no one knows what i'm going
through no one knows how i'm dealing
with it so i can use that as an excuse
i would just about to say you know it
was it's almost even though it's cool
and everything that's almost dangerous
what not to say you've done
intentionally but i was going to say
that when you get fit at the press and
when you go into those meetings where
women will talk about problems and
things happen they'll make that their
problem
so what you've just said
they you've got women in here that don't
agree
and just like what was it just like when
me and stephen they said about us men we
understand we're not understanding
because we just understand we can give
you examples as to why we're saying in
terms of protecting ourselves and the
serious consequences has happened
as regards of not having that evidence
women might have that evidence and as
pearl just said to you
you hear me she um
and what's her name i forgot
she walked
she's walked so all of that situation if
it was the other way around
johnny jet would be in jail and that's
that's what we're trying to say period
wait but wait before you carry on before
you carry on can you put your phone away
please oh sorry thank you
okay so i'm going to read it and then
i'm going to put my phone down so
menstrual cramps
or
dysmenorrhea
has been
sorry
as it's technically called has finally
been ruled as painful as having a heart
attack professor of reproductive health
at university college of london i would
say some i was yeah
even even let's say that's true
it's still not an excuse and and when we
when we when you say things like
oh like but when you add a but when you
add a butt it just takes away all the
accountability so you say a woman might
do this because but it should just be
that's wrong period but wait no but wait
yeah
we're saying this about women yeah and
period cramps and heart attacks yeah but
we're not saying to men it's not okay
for you to say i want to have sex so i'm
going to do this and i'm going to do
that and then when you don't want to
protect yourself and a woman gets
pregnant you want to be annoyed because
she has your baby
so you are going
okay let's so the reason that i say that
women are more accountable for pregnancy
than men is because we can go on the
pill we can get an iud
we can require that the people we sleep
with wear condoms we can choose
abstinence we can wait till we're to
have sex till we are married and even if
it goes wrong we can get an abortion
after pill yeah and the morning after
pill
all of that we can give up the kid for
adoption there are cases where the man
wants the kid and the mother still gave
it up for adoption
where the men just has a condom that she
can steal
so
yeah i think it's our own damn fault
what i'm saying about this period thing
is you're saying yeah but it doesn't
affect all women
it may affect different women at
different points of their lives so a
woman might have i might have a period
that's as painful as a heart attack this
week and next month it may be completely
light and painless but you don't know
what hormones are going through that
woman's body at that time i'm not saying
it's an excuse for women to do whatever
they want to do but then why bring it up
by bringing it up at all because there's
complexities no there's no complexity
where poor behavior is unacceptable i
don't care if she's on her period i
don't care what hormones she's on like
poor behavior is unacceptable from women